other than convolutional layers
confidence often also use pooling layers
to reduce the size of the representation
to speed the computation as well as make
some of the features it detects a bit
more robust let's take a look let's go
through an example of pooling and then
we'll talk about why you might want to
do this suppose you have a four by four
input and you want to apply a type of
pooling called max pooling and the
output of this particular implementation
of max pooling will be a two by two
output and the way you do that is quite
simple take your four by four input and
break it into different regions and I'm
going to cover the four regions as
follows and then in the output which is
two by two each of the outputs will just
be the mask from the correspondingly
shaded region so in the upper left
I guess the max of these four numbers is
nine upper right the max of the blue
numbers is 2 lower left the biggest
number is six and lower right to the
biggest number is three so to compute
each of the numbers on the right we took
the max over a two by two regions so
this is as if you're applying a filter
size of two because you're taking a two
by two regions and you're taking a
stride of two so these are actually the
hyper parameters of mass pooling because
we start from this filter size is like a
two by two region that gives you the
nine and then you step it over two steps
to look at this region to give you the
two and then for the next row you step
it down two steps to give you the six
and then step it to the right by two
steps to give you three so because the
squares are two by two F is equal to two
and because you you know stripe I to s
is equal to two so here's the intuition
behind what max pooling is doing if you
think of this four by four input as some
set of features or maybe not
if you think of this 4x4 region as some
sort of features deactivations in some
layer of the neural network then a large
number means that it's maybe detect to
the particular feature right so the
upper left-hand quadrant has this
particular feature maybe a vertical area
or maybe an eye or what's terribly
trying to detect niqab but you know the
clearly that feature exists in the upper
left-hand quadrant
whereas this feature maybe doesn't cat
my detector whereas this feature doesn't
really exist in the upper right-hand
quadrant so what the max operation does
is Salons the features detected anywhere
in one of these quadrants it then
remains preserved in the output of max
pooling so what the max operates to does
is really safe you know if this feature
is detected anywhere in this filter then
keep a high number but if this feature
is not detected so maybe if this feature
doesn't exist in the upper right hand
quadrant in the max of all those numbers
is throw itself quite small so maybe
that's the intuition behind max pooling
but I have to admit I think the main
reason people use max pooling is because
it's been found on malla
in a lot of experiments to work well and
the intuition I just described despite
it being often cited I don't know of
anyone you know fully knows if that's
the real underlying reason I don't have
anyone knows that that's the real
underlying reason that max pooling works
well in confidence um
one interesting property of max pooling
is that it has a set of hyper parameters
but it has no parameters to learn right
there's actually nothing for gradient
descent to learn once you've fixed FNS
is just a fixed computation and gradient
descent doesn't change anything
let's go through an example with some
different hyper parameters here I'm
going to use here you have a 5x5 input
and we're going to apply max cooling
with a filter size that's three by three
so f is equal to three and let's use a
stride of one so in this case the output
size is going to be three by three and
the formulas we're developed in the
previous videos for freaking out the
output size for a cons layer those
formulas also work for max pooling right
so that n plus 2p minus F over s4 plus
one that that formula also works for
figure out the output size of export but
in this example let's compute each of
the elements of this 3x3 output the
upper left-hand elements were going to
look over that region so notice this is
a 3x3 agent because the filter size is 3
and to the max there so that's gonna be
9 and they were shifted over by 1
because which you can stride of one so
that matter in the blue box is knowing
let's shift that over a game or the
mat-su the blue box is 5 and then let's
go on to the mix row astride of one so
we're just stepping down by one step so
max in that vision is 9 max in that
region is 9 max in that region so the 2
files from the max of 5 and then finally
max in that just eight max in that 6 and
max in that there's none in the right
hand corner okay so this will just set
the hype around to this effort of 3 s
equals 1 gives that output shown on it
now so far I've shown max pulling on a
2d input if you have a 3d input then the
output will have the same dimension so
for example if you have 5 by 5 by 2 then
the upper would be 3 by 3 by 2 and the
way you compute max pooling is you
perform the computation we just
described on each of the channels
independently so the first channel which
is shown here on top is still the same
and then for the second channel I guess
this one's I just drew at the bottom you
would do the same computation on that
slice of this volume and that gives you
you know this second slice and more
generally if this was 5 by 5 by some
number of channels the output would be 3
by 3 by that same number of channels
and the max cooling computation is done
independently on each of these n C
channels so that's max pooling um that's
one of the type of pooling that isn't
used very often that I'll mention
briefly which is average pooling so it
does pretty much what you'd expect which
is instead of taking the maxes within
each filter you take the average so in
this example the average of the numbers
in purple is 3.75 then that's one point
two five and four and two and so this is
average pooling with hyper parameters f
equals to s equals two you can choose
other hyper parameters as well so these
days max pooling is used much more often
than average pooling with one exception
which is sometimes very deep in the
neural network you might use average
pooling to collapse your representation
from say 7 by 7 by 1000 and average over
all the spatial extents to get 1 by 1 by
1000 we'll see an example of this later
but you see max pooling use much more in
the neural network than average pooling
so just to summarize the hyper
parameters for pulling are if the filter
size and s destryed and may be common
choices of parameters might be f equals
to s equals 2 this is used quite often
and this has the effect of roughly
shrinking the height and width by a
factor of about 2 and the common choice
of parameters might be f equals to s
equals 2 and this has the effect of
shrinking the height and width of the
representation by a factor of 2 have
also seen that equals 3 s equals 2 used
and then the other hyper parameter is
just you know the binary bit that says
are you using max pooling or are you
using average pooling if you want you
can add an extra hyper parameter
for the padding although this is very
very rarely used when you do max pooling
usually you do not use any padding
although there is one exception that
we'll see next week as well but for the
most part max pooling usually does not
use any padding so the most common value
of P by far is P equals zero and the
input of max pooling is that you input
the volume of size that NH by NW by NC
and it would output a volume of size
given by this right so assuming there's
no padding by and some of you minus F
over s is 1/4 by and C and so the number
of input channels is equal to the number
of alpha channels because pooling
applies to each of your channels
independently one thing to note about
pooling is that there are no parameters
to learn and so when we when you
implement back prop you find that there
are no parameters that backdrop will
adapt through max pooling instead
they're just these hyper parameters that
you set once maybe set once by hand or
set using cross-validation and then
beyond that you know you're done then
it's just a fixed function that the
neural network computes in one of the
layers and there is actually nothing to
learn it's just a fixed function so
that's it for pooling in D so that's if
a pooling you now know how to build
convolutional layers and pooling layers
in the next video let's see a more
complex example of a confident one that
will also allow us to introduce fully
connected layers